hey und herzlich Willkommen zu glogm Tag
2 ich bin jetzt gerade in York unterwegs
und fahre nach buxte Hude denn wir
besuchen den besten Imbis aller Zeiten
den Imbis von meinem Schwager und warum
starten wir das Video hier im Auto weil
ich euch einfach zeigen möchte dass ich
wieder Auto fahren kann ich bin 8 Jahre
lang bin ich nicht Auto gefahren weil
ich mich einfach nicht getraut habe und
dann habe ich irgendwann
angefangen einfach so wieder zu fahren
so random und dann hat einfach geklappt
das soll man sagen ja und jetzt fahre
ich hier mit 20
[Musik]
kmh wir tun ein bisschen die Beine weh
von gestern ich habe aber keine blauen
Flecken oder so ein bisschen sieh man so
Druckstellen ich glaub ich habe meine
Socken doch nicht so perfekt angehabt
und das aut so was
ist Kälte glaube ich eingefroren der
Wagen na gutfahren wir jetzt malch das
ist die Polizei habe ich
vor Polize jetzt bin ich nervös jetzt
ist die Polizei hinter
mir
scheiße cool ich bin überhaupt nicht
cool so nervös gerade Bo wenn wir jetzt
on camera haben wie die mich anhalten
bitte fahr nicht in unsere Richtung und
nein er fährt nach
links das
ist okay jetzt bin ich wieder gut dann
gleich in buxehude wir sind jetzt hier
auf dem tomparkplatz in buxte Hude und
wir haben jetzt die ganze Zeit schon mit
Ahmed Content für sein Instagram Profil
gedreht also dass er so coole res hat
und Fotos und so die posten kann und
jetzt tun wir so als ob ich kommen würde
und wir uns jetzt erst sehen und dann
teste ich mich mal durch seine Karte
weil wir konnten jetzt bis jetzt so
nichts probieren will NS zum Schnee
sagen ach so ja das Wetter also mein her
über de Gesicht mein Herz lacht voller
Freude bei dem Wetter ich meine wir
hätten eine schönere Kulisse fmer nach
da da ist ein bisschen Weihnachtsdeko da
passt das so ein Parkplatz mit Schnee
ist halt auch nicht so
ne so cool so wen haben wir denn da hi
der der Mann die der Mythos Legende oh
du hast Dings hi das ist Ahmed das ist
mein Schwager hallo ja sie haben hier
die bikernbude Buch Hude eröffnet ne
genau war das schon langer ein Traum von
ihnen ja da träume ich schon länger von
genau war Bude aufzumachen wollte schon
länger so ein kleinen balkkanladen
öffnen hat sich leider so ergeben dass
ich jetzt eine invbisbudel gekauft habe
und selbstständig gemacht habe auf der
hast gerade leider gesagt wie bitte hast
du gerade gesagt das hat sich leider so
ergeben weiß nicht hat sich leider so
leider also das die Bude ist natürlich
der erste Stein und dann kommt das
Imperium dann kommt das Bern Haus habe
ich e leider gesagt
dann hat sorry da habe ich nicht
versprochen das ist ja die balkanbude
und es gibt hier kein Schweinefleisch
also alle currywurste und Bratwürste und
so die ihr bekommt das ist immer Rind
oder Geflügel nur wo wir gerade bei
Weihnachten sind ne das Fest der
Christen machst du uns mal ich habe
schon gesehen Du hast auf der Karte ein
balkanant tell genau kannst du uns den
balant tell machen gerne ja hast du
Hunger du hast auch Hunger ne wiren ich
auch Hunger wir haben so hunger sind
schon so durch geforen wir haben ja
schon die ganze Zeit hier Content
gefilmt ich schneid mal irgendwas rein
was wir gefilmt haben boom drohenshot
boom POV Bo ja hier haben wir die guck
mal hier ist die Speisekarte ich zeig
dir mal bodensuppe gibt's immer
mittwochs und freitags habe ich schon
gehört wie das Kunde gesagt hat dann
haben wir den balant Teller das größte
ch zer fer plkaviz bal Frikadelle was
ist ist das ist balfikadelle ja bal
Frikadelle die zum gleichen
windindfleisch wie die
sind okay ja metos Curry dog schneide
ich euch auch mal hier rein den werden
wir jetzt nicht bestellen so sieht er
aus und ein Tee kannst du mir gleich mal
machen wie ist ein bisschen kalt bitte
bitte bitte bitte lieber Schwager meine
Schwester und er sind so deswegen ist
das mein Schwager haben auch ein Kind
zusammen die war noch gerade hier aber
die sind schon leider wieder gegangen
wir gucken uns in derzeit mal ein paar
Tannenbäume an ne du machst ja hier
ma
[Musik]
ein
bikantella oh vielen Dank lieber
Schwager du bist ja der beste Mensch oh
oh oh oh oh oh oh das müssen wir uns
aber Teilen weißt was Du gerade nicht
gefilmt hast
ne meine Schwester kam mit einer
wermflasche willst du den Schal ich habe
ihn angezogen dass er meine Wärme
annimmt meine du Schwester macht sich
nur s du hast irgendwas hast du damit
auch gemacht du hast es dir in den Bauch
gepackt oder
so e daran erkennst du meine Schwester
schon Mutter ist sie packt die Dinger in
ihre Brust rein um Ihre Körperwärme an
die Handschuhe zu
kriegen du bist verrückt und Trinken te
wollst du aber Tee Ahmed hat das schon
gesagt wir haben hieribi wir haben hier
plkaviz das ist ein Balkan Burger und
pomis undm EA okay ich probiere
[Musik]
jetzt so
hunger alles in meinem Körper zittert
gerade weil wir so ausgekühlt sind das
ist richtig lecker das fre ich mich zu
hör scherin
[Musik]
boah hau rein
Timo
se gut
endlich was Warmes im
Körper rüerwurst schmeckt voll gut und
das ist jetzt plcaviz im
[Musik]
Brot schmeckt als ob ein Burger
und ein Döner ein Baby gemacht
haben das ist richtig gut
leute das ist saftig das ist knusprig
ich red wie dieser wie heißt denn der
wir führen gerade eine Debatte ob solche
Pommes oder geriffelte besser sind du
hast nur nur die malft die Kamera du
verdeckst gerade über den Winter der
dieses Jahr kommt und sie ist
Meteorologin neben beruflich und sagt
dass es dieses Jahr wie 201 wird ne ja
ja kein Kommentar vor Kamera die geheime
tiktokquelle spricht aus mir woher hast
du diese Information habe ich bei tiktok
gesehen das ist so der absolute stand
der arme ist jetzt kalt meine Schwester
ist ganze n so ist so kalt und der arme
a ist so
kalt der arme achm muss jeden Tag sein
eigenes esschen
Essen ja das Essen hat mega gut
geschmeckt danke Ahmed also falls ihr
mal die wbudde buxude besuchen wollt wie
ist die Adresse
hierrad Straße
1auerra ne Krad Adenauer Allee 1 Konrad
Adenauer Allee 1 jetzt haben wir es beim
kleinen Baumarkt beim kleinen Tom
Baumarkt in Bux Hude ihr unterstützt
kleinen lebensstraum komm vorbei wir
haben schon ausgemacht 10% ne wenn man
malwanne sagt bekommt man 10% auf seine
Bestellung dann muss immer rechnen was
10% weniger warst du gut in Mathe ja
also Leute Rabattcode
malwanne x
malwanne dann stehen die Leute sagen ich
hätte gerne
malwanne der rabatcode heißt ich komme
von malwanne sag nicht nur einfach
malwanne ich gehe jetzt tschüss Leute
ich muss zurück nach Berlin ach so danke
für warte ich hab ich
[Gelächter]
hab gleich an mein Mann
weitergeben es ist ein
Eisbär war ganz warm danke euch danke
malw dass du da warst dass du mein Essen
gekostet hast ich hoffe es hat
geschmeckt freue mich auf das nächste
Mal noch vi Erfolg ah men kommt der
Bruder auch noch ins
Video es ist auch kein Brude Besuch wenn
nicht wenigstens ein Bruder mal
vorbeikommt
hi
hi sind jetzt zu Hause und da heute der
erste ist also ihr seht das am zweiten
aber heute ist ja der erste mache ich
mein erstes Adventskalendertürchen noch
auf ich bin so müde ich bin vier Stunden
nach Hause gefahren aber das lasse ich
mir natürlich nicht
nehmen das ist mein Adventskalender
dieses Jahr 24 days auf Rätsel Rätsel
Adventskalender und kreuzwort
Rätsel möchtest du noch was zum Tag
sagen es war ein bitter kalter Tag es
war wirklich ein bitter kalter Tag es
war sehr bitterkalter Tag wir haben da
jetzt 4er Stunden draußen gestanden
viinhb und wir hatten beide keine
Klamotten an für -3° und Schnee und
richtig dumm ja irgendwie schon ne weil
wir ja wussten dass wir das machen ja
wir wussten es die ganze Zeit seit einer
Woche wussten wir es na ja und aber
sonst war es schön es war irgendwie
schön Zeit mit meiner Schwester zu
verbringen mit meinem Schwager jetzt
habt ihr mal den Laden gesehen geht da
gerne mal vorbei das mit dem Rabattcode
war tatsächlich kein Witz das könnt ihr
gerne machen dann kriegt ihr ein
bisschen Rabatt wir sehen uns morgen
schon wieder soll ich schon sagen was
wir machen wir dekorieren unsere Wohnung
mal gucken erstmal unseren Keller
ausmessen aber das sehen wir dann
einfach mal Leute blogm ist wieder
zurück gute
Nacht
ich sehe aus wie eine Verrückte okay
tschüss